Mark's Alvis learned this the hard way
Salas wasn't simply a loyal Democrat he
was the head of Allegheny County
Pennsylvania Democratic Party also a
military veteran you think he'd be
allowed to stick up for America once in
a while but no he made the mistake of
writing this in a Facebook post quote I
stand for the flag I kneel at the cross
now not so long ago most Democrats would
have nodded in agreement at that today
it's hate speech and he lost his job but
tonight their losses are gained and Mark
salvus joins us now mark thanks a lot
for coming on the show
did I miss state that I mean did you
have to leave your job running the
county's Republican rather democratic
party because of those words on Facebook
well I was the executive director of the
county party and yes basically that's
exactly what happened because of that
post which I remind you was over a year
ago that I posted that I was asked to
resign yes so you're a veteran you say
you stand for the flag and you were
denounced as a racist for that correct
the people who brought this to light
tried to tie it to the NFL players
taking a knee so I'm look I'm confused
I'm not a democratic voter never have
been but you know I've been here a long
time not a lot of decent patriotic
Democrats it doesn't seem like that long
ago it wouldn't have been weird for the
head of a Pennsylvania Democratic County
party to say I stand for the flag and
kneel before the cross would it have
been five years ago a crazy thing to say
absolutely not and and I can tell you
that even just last year when the
Pittsburgh Steelers decided to stay in
the locker room instead of come out for
the national anthem
one player villanueva who's an Army
Ranger came out and stood by himself
with his hand over his heart and he was
not considered a racist so this even as
much as a year ago it would not have
been unheard of to hear somebody a
leader in the party defend the flag so
what I mean you're the executive
director of the party you obviously know
a lot of Democrats in your County a
traditionally democratic County what if
what if you're your former co-workers
said to you since this happened I
haven't heard from any of them I
understand the party line is that it is
a personnel matter and I can respect
that however those that are elected
officials or party members who are not
with my direct sort of chain of command
if you will I have not heard from any of
them that's shocking what does this say
to you about how the parties change well
it makes me wonder if there is room for
moderate Democrats in the Democratic
Party nowadays there were some elected
officials who said that they acknowledge
that they've known me and I'm not a
racist
however it was insensitive and
unfortunately if my patriotism and
standing up for family friends has
become insensitive that I think we as
Democrats need to stop and reevaluate
exactly what we stand for if standing up
for the flag is considered racist then
what happens to the country do you think
going forward that's that's a good
question I'm a little worried about that
what are you gonna do well I'd like to
continue to bring this to light and
continue to voice concern for this very
issue and then in the short term
ironically my son is going in the Air
Force in 60 days so I'm gonna spend some
time with him and in the and I will
continue to fight this cause as long as
I can and continue to clear my name
god bless and let me just say again I'm
not supported the Democratic Party but I
hope you stay in that party because I
think it needs normal people so thank
you you know I hope you remain mark
thanks very much for sharing that's a
shocking story appreciate it thank you